hello everyone and welcome back to game
review my name is Caleb Denby and today
we're gonna be looking at a game between
Alexis sheriff and Jew and June that was
actually played earlier in 2019 so this
was a pretty interesting game Europe
starts this game by going a d4 g1 jr.
sponge with Knight f6 and the game
continues with c4 e6 Knight f3 d5 and g3
and we are firmly in a Catalan of course
there are many responses to the Catalan
qu in June actually went for a pretty
interesting one it's more of a modern
one although the idea is a few years old
now it's to give this check with Bishop
b4 and this is a pretty interesting idea
actually the idea for black is that
there's no comfortable way to respond to
this check all three of these moves
actually have their downside although
three all three moves have been tried
and are playable Knight c3 this Knights
just a little bit uncomfortable being
pinned here and you might run into some
trouble involving this pin for example
the e4 score is a bit weak Black has the
option to kind of take on on c4 as well
and already pressure on the centre 92
has some obvious problems to it as well
you're blocking in this Bishop blocking
in this Bishop it's it's not super
comfortable and lastly Bishop d2 is what
was played in this game and it's what's
played most often but the problem is
here now your bishops just kind of
interfering with your own pieces it's
also kind of blocking some development
for for white so normally in response to
Bishop d2 black drops this Bishop back
to e7 and the reason for that is that a
very common idea for white is to drop is
to expand in the center with E 4 and
after efore you're gonna run into the
threat of e5 if you bring this Bishop
back to d6 and for that reason Bishop e7
is a much more common move and it's
actually a better move in my opinion in
this game however black actually went
for Bishop d6 a very interesting
decision and because of that white plays
very aggressively in the center white
immediately plays Knight c3 black
responds with
six and white plays Queen c2 before even
developing the Queen's the the King side
and castling white is already playing
for this movie for he's doing this as
quickly as possible because he knows the
black pieces are ill placed to to meet
this threat black went ahead and got
castled but now sheriff expands
immediately with efore and due to the
placement of these pieces black is
actually forced to go in for this line
where she captures on e4 white
recaptures black recaptures Mike takes
once again and now after ninety seven
you can kind of see that white just has
a slight advantage in activity here this
Queen is placed on a very powerful
central square black is going to try to
kick it away with Knight f6 but already
some devastating Kings side threats are
going to come to two blacks King here
white continues with Bishop d3 natural
development threatens checkmate never a
bad thing
luckily for June when June she didn't
miss it
with Knight f6 Alexei Sharov simply
brings this queen over to age for
keeping the pressure up on this Kings
side in the game black chose rook e8
perhaps this move isn't going to get the
defensive job done although it's
difficult to actually find a better move
for black here it's it's really tough to
find a useful move perhaps you can try
and challenge the center immediately it
was something like b5 or even a c5 but
these moves also aren't really getting
the job done in fact we'll see b5 is
tried momentarily here rook e8 white
actually castles and now black tries b5
and I'll let you at home
give give yourself a moment here try and
find Alexis she Rob's response to b5
it's a pretty combative move trying to
open up your King on c1 so see if you
can figure out how it Lexie navigated
this threat alright hopefully you found
it it was of course the move c5 keeping
these files closed for the moment but of
course sacrificing this pawn after
Bishop takes c5 there's this annoying
pin on the D file that white will have
to deal with and now the fantastic
follow up that Alexis Yara found in the
and played is the incredible move g4
completely ignoring blacks threats in
the center and instead going for the
throat with this move g5 and these
mating threats on h7 Jew and June rose
to the challenge and played Bishop takes
d4 of course now the natural follow-up
is g5 hitting this Knight forcing it
away from the age 7 square but this
allows you and Jun to go for Bishop
takes B to check and now with the threat
to the bishop it'd be a huge mistake to
take on c2 or to take on b2 blackwood
recapture on d3 and now you've lost your
greatest attacker in the game so rather
than take the bishop white actually uses
this king as a defender here defending
his strongest attacking peace with the
king and now black brings this queen up
to d5 trying to create more threats
around this King why it simply captures
this knight on f6 not for the material
but in this case in order to get at this
King black recaptures the bishop takes
f6 we see Queen takes h7 King f8 Bishop
b4 check c5 and now we'll let you at
home once again pause the video try and
find the killer knockout blow for a
Lexie shear off here it's a good one
you'll want to you want to be able to
find it it's what makes this game pretty
special from last year okay hopefully
you found it it is of course first king
queen h8 check King e7 and then the
astounding Queen takes e8 this is the
move that knocks black out of the game
black recaptures on e8 but this allows
of course Bishop takes b5 check King d8
was played in the game and now even
better than taking this Queen is to play
Bishop c6 as a Lexie sheriff does in
this game and he was the winner as June
when June resigned after Bishop c6
of course Queen takes d1 rear takes d1
the King has to move again and after
Bishop takes a 8 white is simply up a
full rook here so a very nice game from
Lexie shear off a very nice Queen
sacrifice
and very instructive showing why the
bishop should come back to e7 rather
than d6 thank you very much for joining
me for this episode of game review
my name is Caleb Denby and I will see
you next time